this video was made possible by the
lovely people on my patreon
a year and a bit ago i sat exactly here
and made a video called a letter to
myself
10 years ago which was a retrospective
on my mental health
telling my younger self what to expect
over the coming decade this video is a
sequel of sorts to that video so
no climate science today no crazy
editing if that's what you're after
then thank you for watching this far i
will see you in the next video
but for those of you who wish to remain
this video is split into three sections
firstly why i'm making this video
secondly my story thus far
and thirdly what i've been doing for the
past year about my mental health
firstly why am i making this video i
think that youtube and social media in
general
has gotten a lot better at
destigmatizing
mental health and specifically
destigmatizing people
putting their hands up and saying i have
a problem with my mental health and i
need to do something about it my initial
video was exactly that it was an attempt
to say look
i'm going to be open about this i have a
problem and i'm going to get help
and i hope that by making that video it
encouraged other people to look at their
mental health and perhaps realize that
maybe
they needed to do the same thing where i
think youtube and social media again
more broadly is
still falling down is the bit that comes
after that the step where
people actually get help for their
mental health and talk about what that
experience is
like in this video what i'm going to try
and do is demystify
and destigmatize maybe that discussion
so telling you
what i've been up to over the past year
and hopefully
that will encourage people who are
anxious about getting help because
lord knows i was anxious about going to
my doctor
and going on medication and getting
therapy i hope that this will make
people who are perhaps in the situation
i was in a year ago that little bit less
worried
and that little bit more likely to
actually go and seek the help they need
secondly my story so far as people who
already saw my first video will know
my problems in my mental health are
basically associated with anxiety and
depression
with an overarching kind of lack of
self-confidence this fear of
disappointing others
this was something that erupted during
my fourth year at oxford and got
gradually worse over my phd and the
years when i started making youtube
full-time really coming to a head about
a year and a half ago which is why i
made that youtube video
then prior to seeking help a year or so
ago i had never spoken to a professional
about my mental health i had never been
on any regular medication and i was
basically a complete noob to this
whole thing part three what i've been
doing for the past
year or so about my mental health after
making my first video i went to see
my gp which was a weight of a couple of
weeks and eventually when i arrived
i had thoroughly overthought the entire
thing when i sat in the waiting room i
was running through all the worst case
scenarios of the doctors thinking that i
was
a fraud that i was making this stuff up
and that i would
be wasting their time all of these kind
of thoughts when i got in to see the
doctor
he basically asked me to explain what
the problems i've been having were
and established a timeline and how long
i've been suffering from
negative repercussions like loss of
sleep
loss of productivity at work general
anxiety those
kind of symptoms when it became clear to
him that i've been suffering from these
symptoms for
more than a year he suggested that i
should go on medication that wasn't
something that he
forced me to do it was something that i
had complete agency over and
he suggested a light dose of a drug
called sertraline sertraline is an
antidepressant and anti-anxiety drug
that i've been taking
in small doses every day for the past
year or so
i imagine my mental state to basically
be a
wave so sometimes you're up you're
riding high you're having a great day
and then seemingly without warning the
next day you can be really down low and
a depressive period basically consists
of those low days
stretching on and on and on and lacking
motivation and
lacking really a will to do anything in
my experience what these drugs have done
is effectively take those lows
and bump them up to a mid level but at
the same time i've also taken the highs
and bumped them down to the mid level so
effectively you're reducing
the amplitude of your wave you're
reducing the contrast so that everything
sits that bit closer to
the mean so this has been wonderfully
effective in reducing the severity of my
depressive
periods they become less frequent and
when they do happen
they're a lot more manageable i feel a
lot less despair
however as i said one of the side
effects has been to lower those highs
closer to the mean and so i've
generally noticed that the points in my
life where i would be really excited
and and really passionate about
something i've just been that little bit
less
so and pixel girl has noticed this she
says that i've become
one of the most indifferent people she's
ever met and that's not something i want
obviously
so my view of the medication is that i
will take these pills for as long as i
feel like
i need them in order to overcome the
symptoms that i've been feeling but with
the eventual goal of coming off them and
that of course will only happen when i
address the root causes of what's been
going on in
my head the medication only treats the
symptoms not those root causes this is
something that the doctor made clear to
me in my
first appointment and referred me to the
local mental health services to start a
conversation about what we could do
about the
long term addressing those root causes
because of where i lived that meant that
i had to
self-refer so i had to register with the
local services
and they then called me a couple of
weeks i think after that
and had a multiple perhaps two or three
hour conversation with a professional
talking through what i've been going
through what i felt like were my issues
and just sort of offloading to somebody
who really knew what they were talking
about
and then they went away and had a
discussion with other people in their
team and i think about two weeks later
called me back
with the decision that they were going
to prescribe me
if you like cbt cbt in this context
means
cognitive behavioral therapy which is
effectively a
program that seeks to kind of rewire how
you look at certain things in life
in my experience one of the key
takeaways for example was changing
operative words and how i view things
like my work
so instead of saying i need to do this i
try to say i want to do this or i choose
to do this
you're not being indoctrinated or
reprogrammed or anything like that it's
effectively targeting a few switches in
your brain and trying to flick them
trying to reset them
with techniques like meditation uh like
reading through the testimonies of
others
and a in my particular case this was a
web-based
lesson plan over i think it was 10 weeks
basically doing multiple
exercises personally i found some use in
this but after the end of the 10 weeks
i didn't feel like i'd made a huge
amount of progress and i wanted to do
something
more it was pretty clear to me that i
needed to do some therapy with a
psychotherapist
and i put off doing this for quite some
time i think because
i was anxious all over again about being
believed or wasting somebody's time
and i probably put off seeing a
therapist for
maybe six months i made it a new year's
resolution to talk to a therapist
and within i think two days i'd found a
website where allows you to find a
therapist
and basically put in there where you
live how far outside of where you live
you're willing to travel
and then the specific things you want to
talk to a therapist about as well as if
you want
to talk to them in person or over the
phone or if you prefer a male or female
therapist as people who've seen my
latest vlog will already know i've been
seeing
a therapist for several weeks now
basically since the very start of
january
fortunately it's actually one of these
things that you are allowed to do
despite covered uh
still being a thing i am able to
actually see a therapist in person
at an appropriate distance waiting to go
into the first session was again
extremely anxiety-inducing for me the
whole worries again about being believed
and there's a pattern can you can you
see the pattern but when i got into that
first session
obviously my therapist is a professional
knew exactly
how to kind of not calm me down but
exactly how to ease me into the setting
and this whole experience and
basically since then what we've been
doing is talking through
my experiences so far and then trying to
identify
patterns certain uh things that keep
repeating through
my experiences and things that i keep
repeating the things that i
keep doing as he puts it the goal of
this is to lead me to doors
and for me to open them he's not forcing
me to do anything he's not telling me to
do anything
at the end of the most recent session he
basically told me to go away and think
about a particular thing but that's been
the only
requirement he has made of me other than
to go in with an open mind and to be
willing to be honest and to listen i
should specify perhaps
this is private therapy so one of the
options with the mental health
local mental health foundation was doing
therapy
in this manner with nhs professionals
but the waiting time for that was i
think about 18 months obviously they're
completely overwhelmed at the moment
and so i decided to not do it then and
do the cbt route
and i have since doing the cbt and
finding it to be not exactly what i was
hoping for
i have been paying for private therapy
this has been 50 pounds a week
and so i am in an immensely privileged
position to be able to afford that and
be able to
use that service and obviously i'm only
able to do that because i have
this job and so if you are watching this
and you've ever clicked on an affiliate
link of mine or if you signed up to my
patreon or if you've bought
my poster then thank you because
you actually allow me to be able to use
this service and it has been
wonderfully useful i anticipate that
i'll be continuing
weekly therapy sessions for several
months we're still in relatively early
days and i think
just at this point we're starting to
unpick
certain bad habits certain bad
mental traps that i keep falling into
and
hopefully over the coming months the
those traps haven't been identified
i will know to consciously avoid falling
into them but again this is still
early days so that has been my
experience with mental health over the
past
year since admitting that i needed to do
something about it and admitting that i
had really quite a serious
problem i have been using medication
regularly and that's been successful but
it's only been addressing the symptoms
and i have tried cbt found it to be not
exactly for me
and have now recently started seeing a
qualified therapist and found that to be
very useful
at every step on this journey i was
scared i was anxious i remember when i
first picked up my medication from boots
i felt like i had a bomb in my bag i
don't know why but i just had this
overwhelming
kind of desire to just take my bag off
and run so if you yourself are at the
position that i was a year and a bit ago
and you know you need to get help but
you're scared to do so
i want you to know that it's okay to be
scared perhaps everybody who goes on
this journey is
scared but that if you do take those
first steps
you are in the care of people who know
what they are doing
who have your best interests at heart
and who
i truly believe will make you
that bit better but also not completely
better this isn't something that takes
place over the
course of a week or a month or
maybe even a year as in my case this is
something that takes
time the important thing as with any
journey is just to take the first
step and don't be put off by the fears
and anxieties that
may be swirling around your head because
i know they are real
i have been there and it's really
important
that you just put a little faith in
somebody else
and believe that they want to help
that's it for this video it's
far too long there's probably nobody
watching at this point but if you have
made it this far then i
hope that it has been useful in some way
or another whether for you
or perhaps if you're supporting somebody
else who needs to
get help as ever thank you so much for
watching and especially to the people
who support me on patreon
and allow me to do this job and in fact
directly fund my therapy costs so thank
you
very much thanks for watching and i'll
see you in the next one
which will hopefully be a bit less
soul-gazy